[Music]
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
welcome to the bonus show as the
republican national convention has
continued this week there's
all sorts of other things happening and
many of them are are
tragic to be perfectly frank kenosha
wisconsin has now seen
protests for three nights in a row jacob
blake is the black man who was shot
multiple times by police
we have learned that he is paralyzed and
that it will take a miracle for him to
ever be able to walk again as per what
we learned from the family's attorney
yesterday they are calling the family
and the attorney are calling for the
officer who opened fire to be arrested
and others to lose their jobs and
the shooting took place on sunday um
apparently uh blake was shot in the back
while his three children watched it was
captured on cell phone video
it is again igniting new
protests now for three nights in a row
it is turn you know i'm trying to use
the less
um i don't know what i'm trying to use
inflammatory term unrest which feels
sort of
less um biased in some way i mean
there's no question that there there is
unrest and understandably so and
um it is getting to be another situation
sort of like the george floyd situation
and i've seen some takes even from some
on the left who say if you look at the
facts
it's tragic but it was justified and
then others who say
how can how was it ever justified to
shoot somebody in the back and once
again pat were right in the middle of
one of these situations
well i've seen the video and i find it
very very disturbing from what i see
in the video it doesn't look like a
justified shooting although there
certainly could be more to the story
uh jacob blake is walking away from the
police while they have
guns drawn at him so in a sense you
could argue that he's resisting arrest
he then goes into his car
so maybe there's a weapon in the car
we'll have to find out about all that
stuff but assuming there isn't
i can't imagine that this would go down
as a justified shooting
especially because like it's not even
like jacob blake was running like if you
if you just put the weapon down if the
cop just puts the weapon back into the
holster and then grabs him
uh he should be able to contain him
arrest him if that's what needs to
happen
but certainly the shooting just didn't
have to happen from what i see and from
everything that
i've been hearing one of the things that
i saw bandied about was that as far as
the officers knew there could have been
a gun in the car and so they had to
shoot him in the back to stop him from
going to the car to get a hypothetical
gun
it's seeming like a stretch to me oh
yeah absolutely and
multiple times too why are you shooting
him in the back even if
even if like you're gonna shoot him can
you shoot him in the leg like why do you
have to cause him to be paralyzed for
the rest of his life
well what police would say is the
training is you shoot for the central
mass because
shooting for a leg is difficult i would
imagine yeah
i would just rather them not have to
shoot at all especially because it
didn't seem like the sort of scenario
where
that needed to happen uh and you know
the protest
it is upsetting but i understand them
there was actually this really bad
situation that happened last night
where a pro blue lives matter kid that's
what he is i guess he's like 17 years
old
murdered someone allegedly he shot one
of the black lives matter protesters
uh in the head and that person ended up
passing away so there's more to
that this is the type of thing that can
happen when there's unrest
um but you know i understand why it's
happening because these these incidents
can't keep happening in this country
i think it was farron cousins our friend
from ring of fire who tweeted
imagine how insane it is that after
months of protests because of what
happened to george floyd
these police officers acted this way and
he pointed out as an indication of how
brazen
some people are and i thought that was
an interesting commentary well that's
the thing
like will we ever fix this problem at a
wide scale
because you know you would think that if
there was any ever a time where police
officers would be more reserved more or
less
reluctant to use deadly force it would
be now the entire
country is focused on them and one
opinion of police is lower than ever i
think
um you know you think now would be the
time when they would be careful but
they're just not
one would think and again most police
are but most police
since the george floyd shooting have
been involved in nothing like this
they've not even drawn their
guns and so i i never want to go
overboard in a country of 331 million
people most police are being careful
yeah and you bring up that point like
can we ever solve this completely is it
always going to happen where we have one
of these unjustified shootings like
that's just human nature right
we're going to have to live in a society
where that happens sometimes you know we
we don't want to accept it but like when
you talk about 330 million people we
have to accept that like it's going to
happen
here and there right if police have guns
i don't see how it goes to zero
yeah if police have guns i don't see how
it goes to zero yeah and if civilians
have guns and the police have to have
guns so like
there's this like futility point i guess
we can make about the whole thing but
certainly when it comes to this case in
this case alone i don't think it needed
to happen
the american associate i'm sorry the
american academy of pediatrics
is um saying that it might be time to
stop these active shooter drills that a
lot of schools do and i know people who
work in schools and have worked in
schools and they've been part of these
drills
and as adults they've said it's kind of
traumatizing
when they come into when when law
enforcement comes in
and they sort of describe what the
scenario might be like and and they run
through the drills
just running through it it has been
traumatizing for the adults
and what the american academy of
pediatrics is arguing
is that it is significantly traumatizing
to the kids
and it's not really clear whether they'd
be better prepared
if there were really an active shooter
in the school
and it's still very rare that there
would ever be an active shooter in the
school
i don't deny for a second that we have a
really bad gun violence problem in the
united states relative to other
countries
at the same time active shootings in
schools are still extraordinarily rare
and so what the aap is arguing is
the risks seem to outweigh the benefits
that you're traumatizing
potentially mostly kids who will never
be
in an active shooter situation and it's
not clear that they would actually be
better prepared if there were such a
situation because things so quickly get
so crazy that it may not make a
difference
i think it's an interesting point that
the aap is making here yeah it sounds
like the right recommendation to me when
i was in middle school in high school we
had lockdown drills yes but they never
specified over what specifically that
you have to watch out for like i think
they alluded to
you know maybe there's a gunman in the
school or maybe there's just like
someone who escapes from uh prison or
whatever who enters the school and you
gotta ride
and we would lock the doors and we'd
hide in the corner uh but i never felt
traumatized by it like i remember people
uh were sort of lighthearted about it i
remember the teacher making jokes
that was before many of the mass
shootings that we've seen in schools
over the years so i know that times have
changed now
but i just wonder if like there's a a
solution where you can still practice
locking down but you don't have to have
like someone as an actor come in with a
gun and like start pointing it at people
and that type of thing
yeah i remember the lockdown drills also
and from what i recall what was supposed
to happen is
the teacher tells everybody to get as
far from the door as possible
um you close the door i think you lock
the door if the docks
if the doors had locks i don't remember
if they did you turn the lights off
you cover the window if you can and i
think sort of wedge a chair
and you don't let anybody in i don't
know for how long but if anybody
claiming to be there to help
tries to come in you don't let them in
in the that's what i remember and
honestly even that got my mind going in
the direction of
yikes what would that really be like
yeah and there was always that issue of
what
like what about the people who are left
in the hallway what do you do with them
i think there is a brief moment of time
where you let them in the rooms but then
how do you know like who's safe and
who's not i suppose if they look like a
student then they're okay but an adult
maybe not
so yeah it was strange but like i i
remember having to do that and it was
normal it was like we had lockdown
drills we had fire drills
and i suppose like the fire drill also
could traumatize me in a sense because
the school could go up in a blaze in my
mind and like that could traumatize me
for life but i don't think that really
happens
yeah and fire preparedness seems far
more reasonable
or or sensible mathematically
maybe an active shooter i don't know
yeah even though they both could be
deadly they both could be exceptionally
dangerous
right i wonder why that is and i think
it's probably because of the media
attention that
of school shootings that we've seen um
you know and it is a big problem but
to make it so that every student in
america has to practice these
uh active shooter drills maybe that
doesn't make sense i remember there was
a
at one point i don't it was sometime in
high school i don't i think it was
probably junior and or senior year
when there was a rash of bomb threats
and nothing ever
actually was serious i think that it was
people who figured out that we got early
dismissal and everybody got sent home if
there was a bomb threat
but eventually that became something
where we were briefed and talked to
talked to about
and i think it was just so
not believable that there was really
going to be an
actual bomb in the school that i don't
remember anybody being particularly
traumatized by it which i think is
different
than highly publicized shootings which
even if mathematically very unlikely
are in your mind during these active
shooter trainings i don't know but it
seems the aap is probably right here
i remember my high school getting a bomb
threat and we all had to go to the gym
uh and it turned out that there wasn't a
real threat the person who called it in
was a student at the school
and they just didn't want to submit an
assignment that was due at the end of
the day
so a lot to do for nothing i suppose the
cdc has
updated its travel requirements in the
context of coronavirus
and they no longer are recommending a
14-day
self-quarantine when you go from one
state to another
or come back from a foreign country that
was the recommendation for a while
now the cdc simply says follow the rules
wherever you are so if the state you're
flying back into or driving back into
says if you've been out of the country
or out of the state this is what you
must do
the cdc says do that but if the state
you're in
doesn't require that then you no longer
have to do it and this has raised a lot
of confusion about is the cdc
saying it's okay to travel or is the cdc
saying that
you still shouldn't travel but if you do
you simply don't need to quarantine only
unless the state says that you do
and what the bottom line is
claiming and we can talk about whether
we think this is reasonable
um they are reminding people you could
be contagious without symptoms
and you can still pose a threat for 14
days
but we're just not saying everybody has
to do it and it's kind of weird because
if that's the case and asymptomatic
spread is still a big risk then
shouldn't people be doing it
and this gets back to the revelation
from six weeks ago
which is a symptomatic spread they now
think is less common than they thought
at one point
but it's not clear i mean it's just we
don't really know
it seems to be the case i feel like
early on we didn't have too many cases
uh here and we saw a lot of cases in
europe so it made sense to
tell people to quarantine for 14 days if
they were coming back from
europe if they're being repatriated or
whatever else um
but at this point the virus is so
widespread in our own country
and foreign countries are doing a good
job by and large at
tackling it i mean there are exceptions
certainly like brazil and india
russia they're having problems for sure
but like so many countries around the
world are doing better
with the virus than we are so like the
the cdc making the recommendation that
you have to quarantine if you're coming
back from those countries doesn't really
make that much sense right
no that part i understand but if they're
also saying if you go from texas
to vermont if vermont says quarantine
then do it but the cdc no longer says
that everybody should be doing as
a matter of principle that seems a
little bit risky yeah it's strange maybe
it's like uh they're listening to trump
a little bit more because that
does have to that does have a little bit
of time with like the federalism
state and local control mantra that
we've been hearing from republicans
lately
and also just trying to make things seem
more normal even when in reality we
still
had you know almost 1300 people die
yesterday and it could be part of an
optics campaign
at this point the other reality we're
contending with is
we don't know to what degree the cdc or
the fda or whoever
are kind of under the thumb of donald
trump and if so to what degree you know
stephen hahn from the fda made this
belligerent announcement about
convalescent plasma on sunday
and then as we covered today on the show
then walked it back and said yeah i
probably went too far there
we just don't know to what degree the
cdc is being influenced here
that relates to that change that
happened with reporting uh when it comes
to chronovirus numbers right back in
mid-july
uh they changed it so instead of states
sending their data to
what was it the hhs now they're going to
send it to the cdc i think it was
hospitals send it to hhs instead of cdc
and it may have already been changed
again it's crazy what's going on
but it's so strange because of course
hhs and cdc those are both under
the trump administration yes both under
the federal government
uh but i guess it's possible that one
has more of an ear to the president than
the other one does
one's maybe one more under trump's
control than the other so like that can
definitely happen
this is why it's just you know when now
we see we've gone from 70
000 cases a day to 40 000 cases a day
have we really
i i just don't know at this point i
really don't know what we can trust it
seems that you go by deaths
you go by hospitalizations i don't know
the answer i don't know what we can
trust
and when you change the reporting
strategy when you change how you
conduct uh tests or how you report tests
halfway through
how are you supposed to be able to trust
it i mean like there's no through line
there's no consistency
and when you automatic when you just all
of a sudden see like this drop in cases
is it really because cases are going
away or is it because there's a
reporting change
and they're covering them up we don't
know we just don't know
uh for the time being i don't know i'm
starting to really get the travel bug
but i'm not booking anything because it
just seems like
even if i could do it it just seems like
more stress
putting aside whether it's responsible
which is a fair question
it just seems like the stress doesn't
justify it yeah i was thinking about
going to like a rural area
uh maybe checking out a national park
that type of thing doing camping
doing stuff that's very socially distant
but i would still have to fly
yeah and i feel like that alone is risky
so i probably just shouldn't do it
there's a lot of places that are closed
uh even like
national parks and that type of thing
they have different spots area areas
closed because of the virus
because they don't want people crowding
in those uh scenic locations
so i think for now i'm just not gonna
travel i'm gonna stay local
uh maybe go somewhere in new england for
this vacation and uh yeah i'm content
with that for a little bit yeah
i'm not apart i'm staying in
massachusetts for the upcoming vacation
i will be doing a little bit of a
driving trip but i will be staying in
massachusetts much like uh i haven't
left the state for a very long time
quite frankly this is probably the
longest i've not left massachusetts
probably in 20 years to be totally
totally frank wow that's crazy and you
went to martha's vineyard which still
counts although barely i would say
because it really is out there it really
is
kind of out there but it is
massachusetts there's no question if you
drive around you see the license plates
or massachusetts plates i confirmed it
myself
uh okay join me tonight quarter past 8
p.m eastern time for night three of the
rnc i'll see you then
or tomorrow the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com